[Music]
the Zelda games are finally being made
into a movie even as a live-action
Adventure the big question is who will
take on the leading roles learn about
this and many other exciting topics now
in the Koch
news rumor has it that Sony apparently
wants to bring the hit game bloodborne
to the movies the rumor about a movie
adaptation of the popular from software
game originates from Insider Daniel
Rickman who has proven himself to be a
reliable source on several occasions
Sony is said to have already hired
Darren lmy as a writer and Transformers
veteran Lorenzo d bonaventura as a
producer who will be in charge of the
project in a statement released by
Rickman he describes the premise of the
story which is basically just based on
the game it is about a hunter who is on
the Move in the decrepit Gothic City of
yarum which is inspired by the Victorian
era its inhabitants suffer from a
bloodborne disease that turns them into
horrible beasts in an attempt to find
the source of the plague the hunter
unravels the city's Secret as he battles
the beasts and Cosmic beings it remains
unclear when the movie will go into
production as nothing has been confirmed
by Sony yet but we will keep you up to
date as
always pure Terror Toby Hooper's horror
classic Poltergeist is to receive a new
series adaptation set in the world of
the original among horror fans the
horror film Poltergeist is still
considered a major classic the film
focuses on the freelink family who move
into a new house only to discover that a
bunch of ghosts are up to Mischief after
the ghosts kidnapped the family's
youngest daughter the rest of the family
joined forces with a spiritual medium
and a Paras to free the child from the
Demon's clutches the original from 1982
proved to be a great success at the time
and was also nominated for three Academy
Awards after two sequels a remake
followed in 2015 according to variety
the story is now set to return in the
form of a series for which Amazon MGM
Studios will be responsible with
Poltergeist the leg Legacy MGM has
already produced a series that came to
an end in 1999 unfortunately there is
currently no more detailed information
about the plot of the new series but we
are keeping an eye on the
project all of Hollywood is breathing a
sigh of relief the actor strike is
finally over for 118 days the majority
of actors in the United States stopped
working to fight for better working
conditions the agreement was made after
the SAG after Union's last offer a week
ago this offer called for higher wages
bonuses and protection against the use
of artificial intelligence the last
point is primarily about the
unauthorized training of AI with the
appearance and performance of the actors
there have already been a few cases
where for example extras have been
replaced by AI generated humans with the
end of the strike numerous film and
series Productions can finally resume
Deadpool 3 for example was halfway
through filming before work had to be
put on hold things are also continuing
for Ridley Scott's Gladiator 2 and Tim
Burton's Beetlejuice 2 which was only 2
days away from shooting Venom 3 can now
also get back on track according to
deadline it is now finally fixed that
the film will be released on November
8th 2024 until recently the official
release date was still July 12th the
planned shooting schedules for spring
are also no longer at risk these include
James gun's DCU kickoff Superman Legacy
Disney's Tron 3 the Minecraft film with
Jason mimoa and Mortal Kombat 2 along
with the riter strike which has since
ended Hollywood was on Hiatus for around
7 months it's estimated to have cost the
Southern California economy more than
$6.5 billion it was the first joint
strike in more than 60 years the coming
months will be particularly interesting
as Hollywood now has to deal with a lot
of postponed
Productions finally Nintendo and Sony
are giving the go-ahead for the Legend
of Zelda movie and have already found a
director for the project the Zelda games
are still regarded as the most loved
games ever and are enjoyed by millions
of players accordingly there is a huge
interest in a liveaction adaptation of
the action adventure the announcement
that a liveaction film adaptation is now
officially in the works is thus likely
to be met with great enthusiasm by fans
as with the Super Mario Brothers movie
Nintendo will be the main producer and
will provide over 50% of what could be a
very big budget according to initial
reports alongside Nintendo Sony is also
involved in bringing the Zelda movie to
theaters one producer will be ABI arod
who not only founded Marvel Studios but
has also produced a numerous Marvel
films such as Spider-Man the film will
be directed by West ball Who Rose to
Fame in Hollywood with the Maze Runner
movies and will also be responsible for
Kingdom of the Planet of the Apes next
year the screenplay is being written by
author Derek Connelly who has already
gained experience with video game
adaptations thanks to Pokémon detective
Pikachu and is also working on the as
yet unrealized Metal Gear Solid film
adaptation as the Zelda movie is still
at a very early stage of development it
is not yet clear when the adventure will
be released in cinemas however as the
project will be a liveaction adaptation
the question naturally arises as to
which actors will portray the legendary
main characters Zelda and Link Link in
particular is difficult to pin down his
appearance age and personality vary from
game to game what's more he was always
mute allowing players to better identify
with him nevertheless various
suggestions are already circulating on
the net they range from dunar Timothy
shalamay to Spider-Man actor Tom Holland
and Thomas Brody sanster who happens to
have already worked with director West
ball on The Maze Runner as for the cast
of Zelda the names of euphoria's Hunter
Schaefer the Queen's Gambit leading
actress Anna Taylor joy and Emma Watson
are being discussed online this is of
course mere speculation at the moment
the producers could also opt for rather
unknown actors at the same time for such
a big project you certainly can't afford
to miss out on some star power who would
you like to see in the roles let us know
in the
comments the first news from the boy
season 4 is here Amazon presents two
legendary characters characters whose
return fans can hardly wait for season 4
of the brutal superhero series the boys
will be released in 2024 two new posters
show homelander and butcher surrounded
by confetti and balloons while
homelander is celebrating butcher
doesn't seem quite as happy with the
situation the festive mood presumably
alludes to the upcoming election day in
the United States which was already a
topic at the end of season 3 Eric kpy
the showrunner of the boys previously
revealed to variety That season 4 will
take place only a short time after the
events of the last episode of the
spin-off series gen V season 2 of gen V
in turn will be set after the boys
season 4 they therefore want to keep the
timeline of the series as clear as
possible in contrast to certain other
superhero universes the events from the
spin-off will also have an impact on the
story of the main series however the
creators emphasize that you don't need
to have watched gen B to enjoy the boys
currently there is no fixed release date
only the year 2024 has been confirmed
due to the delay caused by the strikes
we expect a release in the second half
of the
year a new case for Enola Netflix gives
the green light for further
investigations by the popular detective
and sister of Sherlock Holmes The
streaming giant Netflix clearly wants to
continue the success of its Enola holes
films head of film development and
production Scott stuber announced in an
interview with collider that they are
currently working on a script for part
three starring Millie Bobby Brown
although there is no specific plot at
the moment the plan is to build on the
end of part two and another case of
Enola in London we can currently assume
that Millie Bobby Brown will once again
take on the role of the titular
detective and Henry caval could also
return as her big brother Sherlock
negotiations with the Stars are already
underway it remains unclear for the time
being when Enola Holmes 3 will be
released since the film is in the early
stages of development a release prior to
2025 seems
unlikely that was all the news for today
we also have a few exciting trailers
available on our Channel such as as
Marvel's Echo Ghostbusters Frozen Empire
and Shogun all due for release in 2024
as you can see 2024 is going to be an
exciting movie and series year we can
hardly wait what are your thoughts about
this week's news do you have any more
information that you want to tell the
community feel free to do so in the
comments down
[Music]
below